foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
ER here and then [__] spot turns
around he's got to look inside the
viewfinder The View Master yeah yeah
that's what I got to do he's in there
clicking it like looking at pictures of
the Eiffel Tower yeah right
[Laughter]
unusual life form readings cat
it is pure energy
Pure Energy Pure Energy yeah you guys
know the song yeah it's Information
Society I don't really like that song
but the best thing about it is the is
the spot just box a pure energy yeah
I think they played that at uh
Barbarella last week that's why I was
thinking of it yep
um oh my computer just came on all by
itself all kind of crazy [__] yeah maybe
you hit something maybe it's not enough
yeah what it is
um grafter says may a fifth be with you
yeah that's a good one uh yeah this is
uh Cinco de Mayo so happy Cinco de Mayo
everybody if you're celebrating that
like I said that's why we decided not to
go out this evening because Cinco de
Mayo along with St Patrick's Day and New
Year's Eve are like for seasoned
drinkers such as ourselves yes Amateur
hour
that's uh and it's like extra douchey
and it's like hard to find parking and
yeah hard to find parking no no thank
you real douchey
um much greater chance I'm gonna have to
[__] clock somebody and then you know
there's also a chance I might have to
clock something I'll be spending the
night in jail you know [__] and I
ain't joking y'all regulars you know
exactly what I'm talking about
so no
I almost thought I was gonna have to
clock a dude [__] today
they were like wearing a Starbucks oh he
was on the phone excuse me his
motorcycle I couldn't hear you and I
said man [__] you I was [__] jumping
I'm a little dude man if you [__] you I
do whatever the [__] I want oh I will
[__] you up and he was like oh okay
you're in front of [__] Starbucks
that means I can automatically kick your
ass automatically I just look at you
hard and your ass is kicked if you stand
out in front of Starbucks and I go in
there I go in there stick out like a
sore thumb I [__] got videos of it
videos of it on my [__] Instagram
I look like Satan I look like the devil
sitting up and it UPS up in there it's
funny little goatee are you getting all
cranky again yeah I'm [__] pissed up
way way wipe itself
well you know what happened [__] had
an injection go bad well I know that's
one thing well that's on you yeah my
[__] stomach it does it does look
crazy what the [__] oh man Instagram
keeps [__] with me they keep sending
me this thing because because I said
something Beyond somebody or outside the
normal guidelines but all I said is I
said that dude's gonna get his ass beat
for doing that to that cat and then
because the dude dude had a video
himself [__] I guess hurting a cat
cat turned and [__] attacked him
it just
I don't know it keeps giving me your
comment goes it can keep getting this
okay I just keep saying okay but it
doesn't go away
second some kind of glitch
Anthony asked terrifier too any opinions
we haven't watched it yet but I just
noticed like a couple days ago that it
was on Amazon Prime
and I was actually going to watch it on
my phone like on my lunch hour but then
I thought well no I'll save it because
Tom probably wants to see it too because
we really liked the first one but I've
heard it's long like it's two hours
which is very long for like a gory
horror movie but
it's gotten like a lot of good reviews
and it's supposedly so gory that
um even people that are like really
really into gory movies were like yeah
it was a little too much even for me I'm
like we'll see we'll see
granther said cops are out in full force
too yeah that's what I mean it's it's a
drinking holiday
um and it's never fun to go out on
drinking holidays because everyone else
is also out on drinking holidays and
those are people that don't drink as
much as we do maybe and they don't so
they're not as used to it so they get
like super [__] up and like I said
they take up all the parking
John Smith said in the UK it's now
Saturday morning we're having our first
Royal Coronation in 70 years oh that's
right
in Charles getting certain or something
I don't know I haven't really been
paying attention I gotta restart this
tablet
it's glitching out on me Danny Rowling
said I just saw the 1933 film The
Mystery of the wax museum that still
holds up and it's worth buying it's in
color which is cool also it's crazy
knowing that everyone in the film is
dead just saying well yeah that's kind
of true of a lot of it we saw the 1930s
it's always like all these people are
dead now [__] the ones from the 80s a
lot of people are dead
yeah we were just watching because
remember
um you know a long long time ago like
Louie actually sent us the um the steel
book of Breakfast Club yeah and we never
did get around to reviewing it I said we
have to get around to reviewing that so
actually last night we watched it we
watched all the extras and all that
other kind of stuff and I uh yeah Paul
Gleason the guy that plays the principal
in that movie is he died back and way
the [__] back in 2006.
John Smith said watched a good film
recently knife plus heart oh I've seen
that yeah it was on shutter a modern
French gello set in the gay porno world
yeah I really liked it actually I
watched it it was probably like a year
or two ago I think I saw it but they had
it on shutter and I watched it yeah it
was really good if you like yellow
movies you should probably really dig it
um let's see what else is going on so
yeah um
to so other than Tom's injection going
wrong and he but he has been painting
the bedroom finally yeah finally getting
around to paint in the bedroom if you
guys want to know what happened to the
ejection that's what I did oh I thought
he was gonna look at that [__] ah look
at the whole area is [__] swelled up
it's like a [__]
it's like a [__] grapefruit in there
it is it's super gross [__] hot as
[__]
burning it's like the size of your it's
like the size of an apple
I had some real powerful
500 milligram [__] test and Anthony
and Anthony hurts man to ingest to
inject it even the 250 milligram [__]
hurts
and usually the 500 you want to mix it
with something else I was mixing it with
MPP but I ran out so I had all this
[__] extra 500.
so I just injected a little bit into my
legs it starts to [__] makes a knot
in your leg I got sick of that so I said
what if I go subcutaneous with just
injected in fat well now you never go in
a lot slower more slowly you know so I
only did 0.3 milliliter that's only like
170 milligrams of it but it's real 175
something like that but it's real um
concentrated and I just shot some into
the fat and it felt okay for about a day
or two
and then it just [__] swelled up man
it's [__] burden
all this damn lymph
yeah it's got to work its way out I
assume yeah
Danny Rowling said looks like you were
impregnated by a Facehugger yeah yeah
exactly oh [__] if something comes
bursting in your chest I'm running the
[__] out of here
laughs
John Smith said getting injections when
you don't need one yikes and I'm a
regular blood donor yeah I mean he's
used to it now yeah I'm used to this
I'm like a human pincushion
he's always sticking needles yeah
it's okay
he doesn't like yeah he injects me in
the arms too usually I like it
you know it's weird well you were always
kind of bothered by needles like up
until because I remember when you first
went to the to the test clinic and they
were like yeah you have to give yourself
injections or they were gonna ask me to
do it and I think I did it a couple
times and he was real nervous because he
didn't really like needles but after a
while like he was just like he's just
totally
he's just sticking in his leg and [__]
like that bother me mango says
injections are nothing try having a bone
marrow sample taken yeah I've heard
that's like pretty [__] atrocious
but yeah so hopefully that um
that goes down some
you'll go down my friend did it with the
same [__] remember he just sent me I
told him what happened he's got the same
stuff yeah I tried that in my ass
[Laughter]
yeah yeah so his ass was all [__] up
yeah he says yes I [__] up couldn't
sit down that's why I tried to give it
to me
there's another way we can get some
grapes we can get some grape seed oil uh
what's made for that you can
mix it in with that make it weaker
that's what we're gonna do I got some on
order
yeah so it's not as not as potent yeah
right it's a special kind of grapeseed
oil that you use it's it's sterilized
and sanitized it comes in a damn
hyperthermic syringe bottle and
everything you just mix it in the
syringe and Shake It Up
to make it loot it you can dilute it you
can I got other sterile bottles I can
inject them 50 50 mix in there to make
it 250 milligram per milliliter and then
just kind of heat it up a little bit put
it in some warm water and it'll blend
and make it a lot weaker
that's what I'm gonna do with it
yeah I mean anything's better than
that
because we were thinking
now he's thinking he's like I don't know
if we're gonna be able to shoot anything
this weekend because
I mean I don't know we could probably
work around it if it's just kind of
just kind of there you know what I mean
yeah right yeah oh okay I just can't I I
guess I lost um
I guess I lost Instagram
I can't get on Instagram anymore
she can't refresh
your shit's [__] up oh they said that
I've made a rude comment
and then they're saying then it doesn't
say that um doesn't say that I'm blocked
or doesn't say that I'm banned or
anything it just is it just says you
can't it says you can't make that
comment we took it down
I was like okay and it just says okay
button I press okay okay and it doesn't
the little sign doesn't go away and I
close Instagram out and then five
minutes later I get a warning from them
again so I'm thinking about just it's
glitching out probably it's probably
glitching I think it's glitching but you
know I don't really give a [__] about
Instagram I don't give a [__] about my
personal Instagram there's a lot of [__]
I don't give up I don't give a [__]
about I don't give a [__] about Facebook
anymore I don't give a [__] about uh my
personal
um Instagram I don't really give a [__]
about messenger I'm kind of I'm kind of
through with certain certain
applications the old ones I like the
newer ones now
I don't really have time to use them
much I just use them you know for the
show and everything like that like to
post episodes of the show it's just good
for the show but they police you too
much you know what I mean I like Twitter
because you can fight on Twitter
you know what I mean you can fight on
Twitter [__] it it's fun yeah I grew
up fighting on the internet
and arguing to me that's pointless
dudes are in there fighting each other
[__] just love it you know what I
mean but then I find that really boring
we like we're like I know but I'm making
fun of each other and [__] you know yeah
to be honest like um some people like
still post on Facebook and stuff but
mostly Facebook is mostly just ads now
so you know what I mean
so I'm not really worried about it like
I said I still post the shows I still
have Pages for you know for the show for
my uh I have my author page and all that
and I still post stuff on there but it
seems like every now and then if I
scroll through the news feed it just
seems like you know 80 ads so
but I think I have a Twitter but I don't
ever go on there I think I just have a
thing where
um when I post something to YouTube or
to the website or something like that I
think it posts on there automatically
but I don't ever go on there
they got porn on Twitter girls [__]
show you know what I mean Instagram
girls and [__] uh webcam girls you
know well we're gonna have to get into
that yeah yeah I mean I'm gonna have to
start another that's that's where all
your business comes from really is
Twitter
according to according to bill bill says
mostly there most of their traffic comes
to them through Twitter
but yeah we'll have to post like
PG to R rated stuff you know each each
account's different
you know I mean you got to keep all your
accounts separate well yeah I know that
I already like I said the Twitter one I
don't really give a [__] about because I
don't ever go on there but um
but I have I mean on Facebook and on
Instagram I have different ones like for
every different thing you know what I
mean yeah they're they're kind of
they're good for business but like like
Instagram it's good for business
but it's not
you know it's not good for conversation
or interaction with people
just trading photos and seeing who's who
and
you know buying stuff there's all kinds
of things you know showing where you are
showing other people what you do
but
they police you too much
Tammy said just out of scare one of our
cats and the dog was sniffing around
some potted flowers at the bottom of our
front steps I picked the plants up and
there was a copperhead snake yeah oh
[__] well at least like the animals
warned you it's like hey you might want
to check that out
yeah let's see so what's everybody doing
out there this evening
because I feel like we're not talking
you know what I mean yeah
because you're
looking at your tablet there's nothing
to talk about
you can you can get something to talk
about what are you talking about we've
never run out of stuff to talk about
you see you need to like engage you know
what I mean
instead of like going off looking at
other stuff and just leaving it all to
me to like sit here and talk no that's
not what's happening
uh let's see try to get back to it
there's Dave hey you two hey are you
going to mannequins tonight probably no
I'm not asking you I'm asking him oh
um
I mean we're not going because it's
Cinco de Mayo and I'm not getting
involved in that nonsense
you know what I mean yeah okay people
are showing up now
yeah Jeff here I said I got on Facebook
because of all the ads yeah they're
garbage yeah it seems like it's almost
all like when I scroll through the news
feed every now and then like I'll see
something like that a friend of mine
posted yeah most of his ads Facebook is
damn near useless I mean only thing I
only thing I do is use it to contact
friends that I've had on there for a
long time I don't even go into my feed
uh some people have sent me messages
I'll respond to but Facebook is just
useless you know it's a
just like I said ads and useless
information and people whining and
crying over things that I can't help
them with anyway you know just I don't
know I'm just not that social on there
anymore you just kind of get you kind of
lose your patience
people that you're just kind of
obliquely friends with
you go on your feet it's like looking
down in the mouth of hell just thousands
of people [__] whining and crying and
I still want to hear that [__]
you know
but that's funny though but most of it
isn't
hard Jaguar said hi guys it's been time
uh since the last time I was here I saw
Renfield it's a Gore Fest okay and cage
you know cages the [__] out that's a
good comedy horror yeah I've been
wanting to see that actually good yeah
we might have to actually go to the
theater and see that all right I feel
like maybe we should man what the money
yeah I know [__] I'm looking at my
account it's [__] Vanishing we're
buying cameras that's the thing and it's
only the beginning of the month too yeah
and it's only the beginning of the month
and [__] half my shit's going on well
I mean that we've been investing in the
new projects yeah I mean you know like I
said we spent we spent um we spent 200
each on yeah just in the past couple we
got a new camera like a GoPro a bunch of
props a bunch of props yeah [__] like
that
so we got new tripods yeah
so and the camera that I got
has a faulty [__]
battery level indicator
rest of it works but strangely enough
if you plug it into a USB port it'll
show battery full
unplug it even with a fully charged
battery it'll say battery empty
and then when you talk to it over your
devices it'll it'll say that your
battery Powers is zero percent
weird that's a lot but it's not it'll
it'll have [__]
full batteries I don't know why and
sometimes if you change out a battery
for a second it'll give you a bar but
then it'll go it'll go away and it'll
show you full bar now look down in there
to see if the contacts were bad there's
no it's only three little contacts
and I even stuck a damn Q-tip down in
there and try to rub on them and kind of
clean them
it's not contacts I don't know what it
is software how much cheaper was that
camera than a GoPro oh it's half the
price oh okay basically even though it's
essentially the same as a GoPro but it's
just a little bit yeah it has like most
of the same features most the same stuff
I was amazed at how
small it is yeah it's like the size of
an ice cube maybe a little bit bigger
than ice cube but not much bigger it
yeah it's like it's like that big
and it has screens on both sides yeah
you can turn it around face it toward
your two selfies and
because that's just like that goes up to
4K I think 4K 30 frames or I think it
goes 4K 60 frames a minute
but I think standard 60 frames a second
which is 60 frames a second but I think
standard is 4K 30 frames a minute but um
I went down in the 1080p
range and the image still looks real
good I don't know if there's a big
difference between
1080 and 4K to the average person
looking at it you save a lot of data you
know yeah if I go on to that
and it has image stabilization
and you can do image stabilization on
anything 60 frames per second and bigger
is my understanding
Jeffy yard said maybe you can write
those cameras off on your taxes yeah you
can as long as you keep the um because
that's what I did like when I freelance
for five years I guess in download the
online receipt huh yeah yeah yeah okay
so you just keep all the receipts and
stuff like that especially you know
especially if we actually start making
money at this I don't know we'll see how
we'll see how it goes I mean this
weekend we really need to because I said
we really need to kind of
um crack down and decide what we're
gonna call it so I can do like all the
logo and The Branding and all that kind
of stuff like this weekend you know what
I mean yeah Mega says go 1080 not 4K
yeah probably and this same camera can
be used as a as a um
as a webcam
so I'm gonna get several of them
so for the price of one uh what's it
called hero8
GoPro
I can get two of these there's only like
after after coupons it's like 160.
for the for the camera it's nice yeah
I'll go get it
[__] I might even plugging in as a
webcam wonder what happened
it'll [__] everything up
yeah because I have this camera going
through OBS at the moment
um Danny Rowling said what's Tom and
Jenny think of that classic 80s Show
Small Wonder about that robot girl named
Vicky you know I kind of remember that
show but I don't think I watched it with
any regularity
the weird thing about it is that
I don't even think that people thought
the premise was all that weird back in
the 80s which is a bizarre thing to say
what that didn't think what was weird
the do you remember that show Small
Wonder from the 80s about the robot girl
no you don't remember that I don't like
I said I don't think I watched it
regularly I did see an episode or two
but like I don't know it just didn't
seem as weird as it seems maybe to now
people nowadays
oh but you
yeah yeah see it's like it's really
small we can do all kind of fun [__]
with that
and then that also has like a little
thing and you can even take a selfie
with it yeah
hard Jaguar said Tom you can do videos
like uh serpent Za riding your bike
exactly yeah that's what well that's why
we thought
because he'd been wanting to get a GoPro
for a long time just to do like
motorcycle videos
and you know once we started thinking
about doing this new project it's like
well we need some small handheld cameras
like that we can use for stuff and yeah
you can put this on your head and he can
also use that for yeah for a bike and
it's like yeah see I could
you
but that was only 170 and it's pretty
nice most of the people that reviewed it
are like uh yeah you know the GoPro
um HERO hero8 Black is nicer but they're
like for the
difference in price you could get two of
these you know what I mean yeah the
difference in the image is not that much
and and really the difference that they
were talking about
they were talking about the microphone
wasn't as good but they've upgraded this
microphone so it's a lot better than it
was
and they were they were mostly talking
about image stabilization
wasn't quite as good
and which doesn't affect us because
we're not going to be doing action cam
and Motors you know skiing and we can do
it but it's not a priority right we're
gonna make torn with this
we don't we're not moving that fast
I couldn't be a slow roll
yeah you can even do slow motion you can
do you can't zoom in it but you can they
got all of them all different kind of
accessories I got a selfie stick come in
I got which that's mostly just for if I
go downtown
selfie sticks they got uh [__] body
cam mounts head cam mounts helmet cab
mounts I got a lot of different it's the
same mount for the GoPro hero8 it's
um anything that the GoPro can do this
can do
this has a little frame that goes around
it and they even have a waterproof box
that can go around it and they'll all go
into standard GoPro mounts
so
everybody that reviewed it who knows
everything all about this [__] was like
yeah for the price that's that's a good
deal so when you go on Amazon
this is the one they [__] recommend
it's the um
what's it called
Picasso
it's the ocaso uh
Brave seven
yeah Caso Brave set it's a brave little
camera yeah they make a lot of cameras
but they make ones that bigger than this
and [__] but the seven is the closest to
a GoPro black
grafter says what is the new project
have you not been here
damn Grant well when did we first start
talking about it yeah last week
maybe last week or a week and a half ago
something like that yeah
um me and Jan are gonna are gonna be a
cam couple yeah on on um
uh [__] uh stream mate yeah we're not
gonna do ChatterBait that's [__] in
front of the Coliseum pennies all right
you got thousands of people watching it
too I'm paying you made more money on
that but we this is more private shows
and [__]
and uh we already got
um Studio setup
and we're gonna be a cab couple and then
we're gonna we're shooting we're
shooting erotic content already we gotta
[__] shot adult content yeah we already
have like you know we already have some
footage probably like two three and it
looks good I've shared some [__]
samples
oh man come on I want the whole thing
man now we got people who are also
creating content
like [__] Oscar Perez and his hot ass
[__] Irish girlfriend sending me
[__] videos and she's trying to get
come down and [__] do a show with us
[__] live here and uh she wants to
shoot some [__] stuff with Jen
yeah me and Oscar like oh man dream come
true
yeah two titty goddesses
he gave me permission to talk about it
he gave me permission to even [__]
show her
she's cute
which I think he did on Wednesday yeah
but she had you know we can do it again
her name is uh Misty
okay but yeah I'm just
I I think that what we should do
probably
is
I know they always recommend like
because like I said we did a lot of
research about this like ahead of time
we did a lot of research about this
ahead of time and um you know a lot of
them say oh it's good to have your stuff
on as many platforms as possible because
there's a lot of platforms out because
the thing about it is we're gonna do
like we're gonna do like a two-pronged
thing we're gonna do live streams
um you know on stream mate but you can
also sell clips you know what I mean
like recorded Clips which is what we
were you know we started recording last
weekend
um I don't know I kind of feel like we
should probably just stick with a few
platforms so I don't get [__]
overwhelmed and Confused like putting
[__] I gotta do only vids or many many
vids is the biggest one yeah and
probably only fans and we'll do and then
screaming yeah well that's what you can
sell clips on I have to look at the
legal things because I know some sites
won't allow you to sell the same Clips
on multiple platforms but I I don't
think most of them have a problem with
it but I'm not sure and the thing about
it too is that streammate if you live
stream like a live show on stream eight
as far as I'm aware at least according
to everybody that I listened to said
that you you know you record those live
streams and then you can break that up
into clips and sell those later too like
for people that didn't see the live
stream I'll show you a little bit of
samples this is we shot this
okay look how good Jen looks
nothing x-rated is going to happen in
this this is just some outtakes we're
making commercials basically here
yeah I can't show anything x-ray I got
some [__] wild [__] here mango said
two prongs I know and I I giggled to
myself like before I said that but are
there any socials we should follow for
this content I mean I haven't put it up
yet
because we're gonna do like I said we
still need to figure out we're gonna
call it we're we don't know we're gonna
call it yet and I need to do some a logo
and branding because I want to do it
right you know what I mean and I when we
get the videos edited I want like
everything to look nice and um so we're
gonna start I don't know we're gonna
open a new I'll probably open a new
Instagram account a new Twitter account
a new I'll probably do a tick tock I'll
probably like some other stuff that we
can just put like teaser content on
there and say hey we put a new video up
or hey we're doing a live stream at
whatever the time is or blah blah you
know what I mean to like keep everything
up
um I don't know it's a lot of work
obviously but yeah I've done it before
as far as like my other endeavors go so
imagine some people are like why the
[__] is Jenny doing this
look why not you don't know Jen
[__] man uh if over the years we have
[__] dropped so many hints about our
connections with people that do this for
a living and inside the industry and uh
some of the people that we run into were
involved and even I would call more
illegal [__] like quick we know girls
that failed a prostitution and um how
what a nightmare that is okay yeah so
this is nothing really for us we're
we're entertainers
um but we see the competition we see the
the uh
um how much money can be made we got our
[__] bills to pay man this house and
everything this will all help
and Jenny doesn't like to work a nine to
five job in a [__] office that's not
her she wants to be here
and we can create our own products
and this is just a natural expansion
uh in into a different Market that we
already have a skill set for video
editing graphic design live performance
acting
there's a lot of money to be made on
stream mate not so much in these videos
but that's more like an advertisement
for stream make yeah you just charge
like a couple bucks for those like I
think most people charge like what like
299 or something because how long they
are it's better yeah
usually between 5.99 and 10.99 yeah a
[__] top-notch video that lasts a 40
minutes or so or an hour that's gonna be
20 bucks
well yeah I don't yeah I can do that
because that's like movie links yeah but
most people [__] do watch little
Clips right A lot of them are watched
over mobile the devices and stuff
um yeah that are like what five ten
minutes long yeah like that and uh so um
there's no reason for us not to do this
because we can do it and for our age we
look real good and that's a new
marketing thing we can Market [__]
cougar angle [__] mature goth [__]
hot chick [__] angle big titty angle
[__] there's so many different angles
that we can do and then um
we're going to keep on those channels
we're going to probably just be called
Tom 13 and gen 13. we're not going to
talk if if you go if if the people on
there are not regulars and don't know us
they won't know who we are but we don't
care if they find out because we're
already kind of public figures they're
going to find out she's got a [__]
she's got a [__] Google account [__]
you know what I mean [__] perfect
author accounts and stuff you know it'd
be easy to find but she's not in a
position where she has to worry about
security yeah I don't really get them
she lives out here and [__] I can
handle any security all right
I was thinking the other day when I was
um a couple days ago I stopped on the
way home to go to the liquor store and I
thought to myself once we start putting
all of this on online I wonder if it if
I'll be in the liquor store one day and
somebody will recognize me uh actually
something I constantly suspect people
recognize them but I don't think so well
that's the thing and yeah I did hear one
woman say like I'm pretty sure that like
people recognize me but a lot of times
they won't say anything like they'll
just stare at you you're tripping I
think they're right
um they're just paranoid
so maybe yeah grafter says cosplay stuff
yeah you know dress up like Elvis and
Priscilla Hansel and Gretel we already
have we thought about I mean we're
mostly just gonna you know goth out like
we normally would excuse me but um we
did think about doing well I got [__]
Bane costumes yeah we thought maybe Bane
and then somebody suggested I do poison
ivy which I was like oh yeah that would
probably be good and then I want to do a
Klingon [__] shoot yeah we were
thinking about doing Klingon yeah
Klingon like a seven like the [__]
the motion picture with the [__] long
hair and [__] you know and um
dress Jen up like a Vulcan [__]
Federation officer or maybe her as a
[__] female Vulcan
I'm down yeah it's all kinds of Cosplay
stuff that we can do yeah like we
probably can't do that all the time
because costumes are the money but
there's one well there's one woman on um
she was on live on uh streamate right
that one that one you showed me and she
does
um she just does solo stuff
but um she does cosplay Wednesdays so
it's like she just does regular [__]
like most of the time but then on
Wednesday she dressed because the one
that he sent me was she was like dressed
like Velma you know what I mean and she
uh had a did she have a bad Dragon uh oh
the one I showed you the Velma one yeah
it was Velma
doing a bad Dragon yeah no no no no wait
a minute oh yeah that one you're talking
about you're talking about the girl from
the castle
yeah yeah yeah
she was a girl that used to go to the
castle here in Florida her name is
Larkin love yeah and she did a real good
yeah I didn't know her but yeah we
didn't know we used to see her around
I don't think she lives here anymore
but um she had a real long time
cute girl
but um
yeah she was dressed up like Velma
uh blowing Scooby the dog yeah she had a
big like not a robot yeah she just had a
dildo
she had the glasses and everything
you're super funny yeah well I like a
lot of the um
what was that other he showed me another
one too that was just like a girl again
she was just like doing solo stuff and
she has a whole
um she just does these kind of Clips
where
suppose the one you showed me the other
day it's like you know she couldn't pay
her rent oh that one yeah yeah you know
what I mean and she at least like has
like a sense of humor about it she
basically just looks like she's whacking
herself in the face with a dick even
though it's like delicious and stuff
it's not like a real person yeah but
it's you can't really tell because she
keeps it like out of camera
it's like really really funny yeah like
she always has like makeup on like she's
been crying yeah her whole thing is
super funny her the whole thing is just
solo ax yeah there's no guy involved but
she's pretending there's a guy there and
she's got a GoPro and a big rubber dick
the angle's just right and the [__]
titles are great yeah you can tell she's
like titles are [__] [__] You Can
Tell She's somebody that I would totally
hang can't pay rent but I got him out
that was one of them can't pay rent
[Laughter]
she also calls herself a fat [__] fast
yeah that's right she's not fat though
she's a little heavy but she's not fat
no I would not call it I wouldn't call
her fat no she's heavier than you but I
wouldn't say it yeah but I she's cute
yeah look at yeah me and Jim were
talking about I said I was trading
pitchers with Jen I was like check this
chick out is this [__] possible there
are some girls out there that can really
carry weight pretty well
you know I would call them fat but they
still look good they still got a shape
you didn't ever get a chance to see it
you're at work because I can't I was
like Jen is this real or is this uh yeah
he sends me all this stuff it's like
what I'm at work and that's like I can't
watch that yeah there's like people all
around
yeah it was real I think see if I can
find her
um Jeffy art said I know a few guys who
do content for uh only fans and just for
fans they do a lot of fetish leather
Kink uh boot content their advice find a
niche Kink and go deep yep yeah well you
oh I kind of feel like because there's
so much content out there you really
need to well it's just like anything
else you have to like distinguish
yourself whether it's with you know one
particular like rare kind of fetish or
you know just having
just something different going on
because there's just so many
there's just so many I mean there's just
so much of it out there and there's
especially like a lot of solo cam girls
who
you know and some of them don't you know
I'm sure you know they're all fine and
everything like that but some of them
don't really have much to distinguish
them from one another they're all kind
of same right I know they don't have
wardrobes either there's only certain
things they just buy real cheap [__]
they kind of look the same each in each
video that's the thing that's one of the
advantages that me and Jen got [__]
badass wardrobes yeah I got two closets
you guys haven't seen the [__] even
the even the tip of the iceberg because
we don't really dress up for shows that
much we just yeah because usually it's
just our regular clothes I just yeah I
mean I just wear regular [__] like I
changed my shirt when I came home from
work but that was about because I just
had a t-shirt on but because I usually
have to rush it today I just rushed home
from work I had stuffed a piece of
Focaccia in my mouth and then yeah got
ready and then changed my shirt and got
ready to do the show you know what I
mean pretty much slapped on a wig
fix my makeup and that was it that was
it Danny Rowling said uh she also did a
video as Elvira that was pretty hot oh I
should do Elvira who did that I don't
know he was talking about somebody
earlier yeah
but um talking about
maybe she's talking about um
I probably need the weight I need the
wig
Elvira would be easy for you to do it
probably would be yeah
because really all you need is the wig
and the dress and it's like and she does
like very specific kind of susie-like
eye makeup and you know and I could just
do that but
and let's see
mm-hmm
Samantha 38G
all day and night
oh Larkin loved the Elvira video yeah
yeah
like I said the one he sent me was just
the the Velma one because he was sending
me like examples
of uh different ones that were out there
because I don't you know I don't have
time to like he's he's more of a porn
connoisseur than I am I know all these
people's names and [__] right this is
the girl I was talking about
How could a woman weigh that much and
still have such a good shape
it's not
it's not just falling around everywhere
I wonder if some of that I wonder if
it's real like well yeah or if it's
that might be implants and injections
that looks like implants because why
isn't gravity taking over right because
usually if you had a butt that big it
would be yeah falling around I would
think so
so okay I got rid of the glitch and I
said Jen I want I want a picture of you
in that position
Jacobs yeah I can do it I think but look
at the size of that girl I haven't I
used to I took gymnastics when I was
younger yeah I'm still like fairly
limber but I haven't done that in a long
time so I don't know if I could do it I
mean I used to do a kick-ass backbend
I'm not sure if that's actually real I
mean she has video of herself
it looks real like okay she's moving in
this look Shawn Court said yep fat
transfer Brazilian butt lifts that
probably is
yeah because I think Brazilian yeah
that's I don't I don't think that's
natural
it's very unlikely to be genetically I
have never seen a person that's been
that was built like that that it would
normally be around the middle you would
think yeah
look at that
chance nowhere near that size
I hope not
that's amazing though it can't be real
no I know probably not it can't be like
I said that's too out of the ordinary I
couldn't watch all this stuff because I
was at work so you know what I mean okay
it stopped glitching out because I went
on Google
I went through my Instagram account
through Google and said okay and it
acknowledged me saying okay okay so it's
must be glitching out well I told you
that happens
yeah Camp guy said uh Larkin love her
main claim to fame is the length of her
child yeah the tongue yeah
yeah looks like Gene Simmons I didn't
actually notice I didn't actually notice
her time but she wasn't she wasn't
really doing anything stuff when I when
because I was watching we were watching
the um
she had recorded a live stream like I
said that she dressed up like Velma yeah
so she was mostly just talking and then
she was doing the thing with the bad
Dragon yeah she evidently hates the porn
industry she left it she only does
independent stuff well I mean now that
we have the means to do that it's like
if you want to get into the adult
industry like why on Earth would you
want to let go with the studios with the
studios and stuff like that you're just
gonna get like rung out and like [__]
over they made her she only did like
four or five scenes with them and they
just made her do [__] that she didn't
want to do and [__] like gangbangs and
[__] see that's what I'm saying it's
like see I wouldn't
with you know when I said this before I
wouldn't really be interested in getting
into that industry if it wasn't
independent and if it was just me and
you working together I don't want to
like
you know end up having to do a bunch of
[__] with people I don't know who they
are and [__] like that that's not that
doesn't letting my girlfriend out to
these [__] men
well like I said if I I don't want to do
that either it's like that really
doesn't sound like a good time and
they're not really making they're making
some money on off that during the in the
studio system but where their real
monies come from is escorting
that's where it's the advertisement for
the escort services and see I I don't
think I would I wouldn't be good at that
oh no to [__] destroy your life
because [__] yeah next thing you know
you can't meet men the normal way you
can only meet them through the [__]
and that what was his name Angela White
said that Angela White said well I met
my boyfriend caming yeah you're like
what and they're like yeah we went cab
to cab and I met him because he goes
because of what I do I can't meet men
the normal way yeah you know just so he
was cool we went out
but see like I said I kind of feel like
it's probably
it's easier for us getting into this now
because like I said it's you were doing
it independently well we're just working
with each other yeah
um you know we're older so it's not like
we have to worry about oh I'm only in my
20s or 30s I might want to you know get
married someday have a family and stuff
like that people might find out about it
or blah blah it's like we don't we're
too old to like give a [__] about that
anymore so
um so you know it's probably like a good
time to get into it
and honestly it's like I hadn't really
and uh she's good
she's good she had fun
she had fun she looked great on camera
well the thing about I it's weird
because I didn't really think that I
would be good at it yeah but I think
like when you had the idea and we
started talking about it I said this
kind of this sounds like something we
should do like I think this would be
really fun and you know maybe we'll make
some money at it maybe we can make
enough money that I can you know quit my
job but we can go back to like working
at home again which would be ideal but I
got like
yeah it's weird that I got like more
into it than I expected to yeah I wasn't
nervous I wasn't
you know I was constantly just thinking
of about camera angles and whether or
not this is [__] gonna look good look
good on film and [__] should I open
up so the camera can see a little bit
it's just crazy [__] like that you I was
worried too much about [__] technical
stuff I hope that camera's running that
kind of stuff kept throwing yeah we'll
be well I mean to be fair it was the
first time we had shot anything and we
spent like hours and hours like shooting
a bunch of stuff like um so we hadn't
really
you know experimented with it before
like with the we had just set up the
studio we just set up the lighting so we
were just kind of like and I was
honestly surprised that we got as much
good footage that as we did
um you know for the first time out
because we did keep being like Oh you
know you know is this angle okay or is
this even recording or because a couple
times like we recorded like we were like
oh my God that was great and they were
like oh [__] didn't record but then you
know what I mean and we did with tablets
right tablets so with the new cameras
that they're being better yeah so that's
why we wanted to get like the smaller
GoPro camera because I said that'll be
much easier to Hold Your Hand yeah you
can hold it in your hand you can move it
around you don't have to like worry it's
like oh you know yeah you know can you
see this from that angle and it's like
you have to keep stopping and moving
stuff around you got one camera running
on you and then you're holding a tablet
with the other hand and that tab is big
enough to [__] obscure the [__]
views of what the shits what the [__]
going on the GoPros are the size of an
Ice Cube It's just in your hand the
[__] other camera sees it but it's
not a it's not obscuring anything right
you know I think that's we both look
good we both look great on camera
and I think too that [__] huge on
camera
I look like a [__] werewolf man all
this upper body and [__] [__] dick
boots and [__]
[Laughter]
look like something out of down Frank
Rosetta painting
yeah you did
it did it came out really good I thought
some of y'all have seen it put pieces of
it
they didn't have it was just a teaser
stuff that was the only thing I could
put out because this files were small
enough stuff that we were doing in
between scenes
you know what I mean [__] um
because the big files I couldn't share
them they're too big
yeah because we I mean you know to share
them over Instagram we had like
well some of the video clips were what
like 20 30 minutes or something like
yeah you can't share anything longer
bigger than two minutes yeah on most
social media we just kind of have it
it's all in myself I still have to edit
all the stuff there because
I just hadn't had time this week to like
go through all the stuff and but I think
we got a lot of good like I said there's
probably at least two or three videos
worth of material in there yeah like I
would I would imagine I think we make
well I haven't seen the [__] that you've
shot she's got some solo [__] I shot
some solo [__] like on Tuesday hopefully
some of it's usable
um
so now we can always do it again we got
new cameras yeah because new camera
might help a lot more if it doesn't if
it didn't come out good like some of it
I think came out good and some of it I
think is usable but I didn't have
um the tablet so I just used this camera
and the laptop and then I forgot that
this camera is attached to this
microphone and it's like so you can't
really move any of this stuff so I had
to just kind of like move it out of this
like chair so I had to kind of like [__]
with the Angles and everything it took
forever and um and then a couple times
this is hilarious but um this just goes
to show that like when you're shooting
adult content
um it's not glamorous in this latest
you're gonna have [__] where it's like
oh [__] the dildo fell over when I was
ready you know what I mean it's like
you're solving problems and if you're a
guy you're trying to solve [__]
technical problems and [__] stay
rocked up and [__] right so you're like
and then that [__] up you know oh [__]
nah come on here go ahead and fluff me I
gotta get back here
then you're like [__] man and then you
start getting into [__] performance
anxiety like man I gotta get this [__]
[__] rocked up man because man then
you like that dude okay okay we're good
okay get back over there okay
because all you know all the [__] I have
talked on this show over the years you
know I was gonna have to back it up
I knew I was you knew it was going to
happen people all the [__] that I've
talked
I can't just I'm glad that you're
putting your money where your mouth I'm
putting the money you're putting your
money where your dick y'all will
experience it yourselves
no it sounds funny but it's like when we
first decided to do this and we were
like both really excited about it I was
like this is
I don't know just like thinking about it
I was like I was like um
I kind of feel like oh maybe we'll get
really good at this and I'll be like I
kind of felt like it was like the light
at the end of the tunnel or something
like that you know what I mean
I don't think about it if it happens it
happens if it doesn't it doesn't it
doesn't matter it's just another product
we can sell yeah I mean you know but
um I'm just I don't know I'm excited
about it yeah it's it's actually really
fun it's you know it's a pain in the ass
because like I said it's probably more
of a pain in the well I don't know if
it's more of a pain in the ass for me
than it is for you because I usually
because I have to like
do all like wigs and makeup and corsets
and boots and all this other kind of
stuff and you don't have to do hair or
makeup or anything like that but um
actually I probably should do some
makeup yeah we were talking about this
you got to do eye sockets and [__] a
little bit of liner and stuff just the
same kind of things you do go television
or right
um just because it depends on the
lighting conditions
so but that first time we just jumped
into it because the lighting conditions
really did it wouldn't have battered it
was mostly red light
yeah see yeah it looked okay I thought
probably should have had a little bit of
[__] Shadow and a little bit a little
bit of eye shadow a little bit of liner
probably would have made a difference
make sure eyes look bigger makes your
eyes pop out yeah
and uh you go with a lighter
shade inside inside here to kind of in
certain Lighty conditions I look kind of
haggard like my eyes are all sunken in
you know
I mean if
I do the whole thing man I do like all
the I do primer and uh the foundation
[__] and then like a little bit of
contouring and yeah I just need a little
bit of concealer all that kind of stuff
yeah
uh Mr 88 says fluff me vocabulary
expanded yes that's and we didn't even
make that up that was right that's I I
heard that term
years ago yeah yeah a fluffer That's
somebody that in between takes keeps the
poor the male porn stars yeah um you
know ready for action and on the big on
the that's what they call them on the
bigger Studio shoots a fluffer That's
All She did yeah
now she might have done some amateur
stuff or lower ranking
porn stuff but her job was just to sit
around blow Dunes in between seeds
yeah she would never even be on [__]
camera that's some weird [__] when you
think about it what do you do I'm a
flubber
because they weren't cute enough to be
on camera in the real high end
porn scene because they look like models
you know
what a job hey I mean anything that pays
the bills you know what I mean
I'm not sure it did who knows that I
don't know how much they were who knows
well I think that I think they were
doing Gonzo too and do you know like
remember the movie remember that movie
we saw [__] with the uh
um
mope I was just thinking they're in that
warehouse doing that [__] yeah I think
those I think fluffer girls worked most
of the time in those yeah if you haven't
seen the movie mope yeah like it's real
it's it's good it's based on a true
story yeah it's a great movie it's kind
of like set in the porn industry and I
kind of feel like a lot of people don't
it's real it happened but yeah it's
based on a true story like it's kind of
a horrible like a horrific story but
it's kind of a black comedy I have it
don't I
I don't remember if you bought it or if
we watched it I gotta buy that maybe we
watched it on Amazon Prime
it's like Boogie Nights but darker yeah
but it has a lot of humor in it and it
was about this
wasn't it an Asian guy and about yeah
yeah that's right it's about an Asian
guy and a black guy who were mopes and
mopes were like ex-porn extras
they were just the dudes that were in
gang bangs and [__] they it's like
they're the dudes that stand around in
the ring and like
on the girl's face you never really see
the dude you know I mean and they're
they're guys that really there's nothing
about them that makes them stand out to
where they were ever going to be like a
name so they're kind of like just
they're just extras
but these two dudes
make friends with each other and they're
trying to turn themselves into porn
Superstars and open up their own little
company but it kind of fails but the
black dude slowly goes insane in real
life
and gets into a confrontation he kills
some people at the studio yeah so like I
said it's a pretty interesting story
it's a true story it's a true story and
then the cops track him down and they
got the news cameras on him this is in
real life they really show it too in the
movie at the end and um they run him off
the cliff he jumps off a cliff yeah they
shoot him too didn't they I think they
did and they got a real it's been a
while but yeah they got a real um video
of him news footage of him
jumping and he's jumping like a [__]
Superstar like he's doing karate and
[__] he was crazy jumping like off the
cliff like he was doing karate and he
hit he [__] it [__] him up and I
think they shot him too
during that uh before that he died it's
a pretty messed up story he killed his
friend didn't he I think he did yeah
yeah
and uh he had schizophrenia it started
to kick and Win It schizophrenia
I can't remember it's been a while and
he was doing drugs too so I think it was
part of it yeah that didn't help it
didn't help
Jeffy Hart said off to my weekend night
job at the bar I'll catch you guys later
good luck is it Cinco de Mayo yeah so
[__] Cinco de Mayo
that's the Mexican Saint Patrick's Day
like I said everything St Patrick's is
bad enough now you can have Mexicans
involved [__] god of Aslan tell us
tell us what uh what Cinco de Mayo is
like over there in Mexico
it's probably one of those crazy well
it's just kind of like it's St Patrick's
Day I feel like St Patrick's Day is
celebrated way more in the United States
in Ireland it's crazy what the [__] we
don't do that it's crazy too we don't do
that St Patty's Day is [__] crazy
yeah everybody here is just like woo
let's get as drunk as possible and vomit
in the streets you know yeah so
yeah see that's exactly Victor says
Cinco de Mayo is nothing in Mexico
there's nothing in Mexico okay I've
suspected as much I said because it's
probably the same thing that happened
with St Patrick's Day which they don't
even celebrate in Ireland well they do
kind of but like a little bit but then
like over here they're like any [__]
holiday where they can just like drink
till they throw up they're like yeah we
want on we want on board with that yeah
you need an excuse
I don't need an excuse I don't know why
other people do
yeah because that's an American thing
that's it yeah just like sit back and
finish that up and I'll go we're out of
juice people
so I'm gonna make vodka
and Fanta pineapple pineapple I got some
fancy pineapple vodka goes with
everything that's why I get it got that
[__] at the dollar store
yeah Santa's good man Fanta orange I
don't mind fantastic yeah it's not like
I better a crush well I'm not a big I
would not be able to tell the difference
if you blindfold it's better I don't
think well because the thing about it is
that I've never really been a big soda
drinker I don't know why it's just like
never like if I'm real thirsty and it's
hot out or something like that yeah I'll
grab a Sprite or something like that but
it's never
it's never my go-to phantas fanta's the
Nazi drink did you know that yeah yeah I
don't know that you see in Germany
during the 30s once mustache man uh once
this party took over before the war
started they were trying to make German
versions of everything that the United
States had
they wanted something like a Coca-Cola
but that was totally anti-national
socialist all right they were like no
that's Brown Sweet garbage it's
capitalist you know [__] Coca-Cola our
[__] is gonna be eco-friendly it's gonna
be bright and fruit flavored so they
made fat to Orange
yeah and it was just Orange
and that was evidently like the German
drink during the 30s and uh the
government was funded it was behind it
they owned the company
every company in Germany at that time
became absorbed by the government
socially you know where they call it uh
not social fascism is is a form of
Socialism it's where the the corporate
Powers merge with the state the state
and the corporations become one
which sounds like a description of every
[__] modern country in the world
right now so I'm not sure how useful any
of these term terms are
like capitalism I don't think it's a
useful term anymore maybe it was in the
1800s part of the 1900s but
none of that [__] it makes any sense
because nothing's capitalist now
everything's kind of like a damn fusion
power they're just printing their own
money it's the Keynesian [__] so I don't
even think I don't even think capitalism
exists
it's some kind of weird [__] fascism
but anyway uh a lot of people don't know
that Fanta
is what the Nazis drink
you'd never know it
well I kind of feel like a lot of people
don't know the history of a lot of where
Foods came from and the thing about it
and it's interesting although you know
most companies have been through so many
iterations since that time the owners
and stuff that it doesn't really doesn't
matter it's just like kind of
interesting yeah like you know all their
uniforms were designed by Hugo Boss you
know the [__] SS uniforms that's all
Hugo Boss [__]
he designed all that
um so a lot of those companies survived
the war they all
you know just the way it is because
everything was part of that government
there was no
there was no business that had not
become fused with the state
so it was unavoidable anything German
that survived the war was that's Nazi
it's just kind of interesting you never
really think something as friendly as
fat to Orange you know it would have
been something
from wartime you know well you think
that companies want to stay in business
so it's like if they have that kind of
Association in their past and they're
going to want to like yeah you know try
and break away from that Association
yeah
but they're just their description of
Coca-Cola is dark and dark and unhealthy
and and artificial based upon it was too
Brown it was too Brown and two two
sugary not white enough
they said it wasn't natural enough it
wasn't that it was it's not it's not
something you would say Santa's not
naturally they thought it was natural
it's just bright and positive you know
what I mean and fruit flavored and
healthy they considered it to be healthy
Sean Court said too bad Fanta has corn
syrup in the U.S I kind of feel like
pretty much all the sodas have corn
syrup
um although you get the Mexicans you can
get well and honestly a lot of throwback
yeah a lot of main Cola Brands now at
least in the US have started doing like
throwback where they have like actual
cane sugar in there yeah and it's not
too hard to find like I've seen them at
Publix I've seen them at Winn-Dixie it
makes a big difference it really does
you go down to the Mexican store over
here it's got a restaurant attached to
it you get Mexican Coca-Cola in a bottle
glass bottle
and [__] it's a night and day
difference
you could drink that all [__] day and
not be overpowered by it it's just crisp
and has a cleaner flavor to it
uh just tastes a lot better
because well if that's the reason that a
lot of um you know Coke and Pepsi and
their brands and stuff caved after a
while because so many people were being
like buying Mexican Coke because they
started offering Mexican Coke and yeah
grocery stores and people started buying
that because it had actual sugar in it
so corn syrup so you know all the brands
were like oh well if everybody's buying
that we're gonna go back to like [__]
sugar too I gotta go down there and so
they have like both options I know that
they have Mexican fruit drinks
I think the sigma is called juaritas I
think it's what it's called I think
juarita is I think it's orange
flavored
Mexicans will know I think it's waritas
is what it's called so with a j
that I don't know if that's I don't know
if that's Fanta that might be Fanta
but it's going to be cane sugar
and they they also had all different
flavors they had the grape and [__]
this picture says it's harito harito
toast j-a-r-r-i-t-o-s
yeah it looks good forget my
pronunciation I'm sure it's bad so
that's not a Fanta Fanta doesn't own
that then it was orange
not the not that I know of okay unless I
mean they might
because they'll market things under
different names it might be cruel yeah I
mean that's kind of the thing like if
you there's another there's a YouTube
channel that I watch all the time he
puts out a video every week call or
actually more than one a week but it's
called company man yeah and he talks
about
um he does like they're like 12 15
minute videos and he'll talk about like
one company and do like a deep dive like
about their history and stuff and like a
lot of it's really interesting but he
does like a series that's called bigger
than you know and it's usually about
something like
um you know Procter and Gamble or
something like that that own like 90 of
the brands of [__] you see in the
grocery store because you think like all
this stuff is different brands because
it has different names but they're not
like they're all owned by the same thing
yeah
uh Camp guy said I love to eat sugar
cane reminds me of being a kid my old
man would buy a stick every once in a
while yeah it's like even when I don't
know
um I kind of feel like the corn syrup
thing was already fairly well
established by the time I was a kid like
in the 70s and 80s but even so I don't
know why I was like a weird kid because
people drank a lot of soda in my house
like my grandmother my paternal Grim
grandmother very famously
um that's pretty much all she ever drank
was Coca-Cola and coffee
um she wouldn't I don't think I ever saw
her drink anything else like as long as
I knew her she didn't drink but she
didn't drink booze or anything like that
but it's like just for every meal it's
like Coca-Cola like in the morning she
would have a coffee a couple cup couple
cups of coffee and then like all day
whatever with a meal or anything like
that would always be Coke she [__]
loved Coca-Cola and you know and my
brothers were into it and all this other
kind of stuff but for some reason I just
never really got into soda I don't mind
ginger ale I don't mind root beer I
don't mind like I like Dr Pepper
actually if I'm gonna get
um a soda like if I'm at a fast food
place or something I'll usually either
get Dr Pepper Mr Pibb
um or Sprite Seven Up but other than
that sometimes I'll get like orange
Fanta or whatever the [__] but I don't
really like Coke I don't really like
Pepsi
um you know I don't know why it's just I
never really got into it I was always
and I was kind of like the weirdo in the
family because all I ever wanted to
drink was water like I just drank ice
water like out of the tap
or milk I drink a lot of milk
or orange juice I would drink orange
juice but other than that it's just like
I wouldn't really drink any soda or
anything I don't know I just did I never
got into it I know that's weird but
um huh this is good
well like I said vodka goes with
everything that's the nice thing about
it you can just like whatever the [__]
you have in the refrigerator yeah it'll
go in there like we even the other day
we were like we didn't have any juice
and I was like well I got like a carton
of iced coffee in there throw it yeah
where the Vodka the iced coffee that
tasted good too
I'm out though there's a carton in there
still but I think it's only got like
that much that's a real that would be
like a real drink because in Brazil
when I was a kid they had a drink oh
that is good called a high five very
refreshing called a hi-fi
and a high five vodka and Fanta orange
yeah and uh that's like like a high five
see I'm sure that would be delicious
Camp guy said I get half sweet iced tea
half sweet and half unsweet
yeah because sweet tea is uh not gonna
lie Pretty Sweet
depending on where you go though
you know
they're talking about the pink tab soda
kit do they still make tab
uh no I don't think they make tab
I remember that being a big thing in the
70s I was like the diet soda right
because it only has like one calorie
yeah yeah I just remember it tasting
like weirdly metallic yeah it tasted
like [__] I mean it's been a long time
since I've drank any but when I was a
kid the only I used to kind of like
Fresca yeah I think they I think they
still make that that's grapefruit right
it's grapefruit Fresco's good
I think they still make it yeah Frisk is
good with that with good with good with
vodka I can see that yeah because
grapefruit invite actually grapefruit
flavored vodka is also quite good
I like flavored vodkas and the
grapefruit one uh deep Eddie makes one
that's like grapefruit flavor that's
actually really good
um
Pokey what's the matter she's well she's
scared
because the room's blue blue now
yeah she's kind of wigging out a little
bit because Tom's painting the bedroom
he's always done it's there's only like
one corner I'll finish it tomorrow for
you yeah and um so because I came home
and I was kind of like well how did
Pookie take it was she coming in here
bro like we I'm gonna jump in the paint
yeah she did that a little bit she tried
to get inside the drop cloths
yeah no concept of wet paint yeah she's
like I don't care yeah she doesn't care
Pookie does what poofy wants to do yeah
but it's dark blue it looks good in
there
it's very nice yeah well it's weird
because it's soothing give a sleep all
[__] day in there it's dark blue
almost black with a white ceiling and I
got all that damn [__] Bliss light
[__] swirling Galaxy nebula on the
ceiling all the lighting effects black
curtains I need to hang some art in
there too yeah our bedroom you could
sleep in there for days if you wait if
you want well that's probably not a good
idea
we'll see I like that though
over the weekend because that's the only
time because you know during the week
when I go to work I have to get up at
[__] five o'clock in the morning
we're gonna keep porn up in that [__]
too well yeah well we need to that's
another thing yeah is that we needed we
wanted it to look good because we've
lived in this house for a year and a
half and we haven't been working and we
really haven't
I've been working on it literally Yeah
well yeah he's been doing like getting
down [__] [__] yeah and he's been
doing like the the garden like the
landscaping and stuff like that which
looks amazing but we haven't really done
much I mean we didn't have a lot of
money to like buy furniture
[__] Authority and [__] yeah like I
said we had a long refund and all that
the new roof that was going to cost us
an extra 300 a month in Insurance costs
plus we got to get it painted like hit
the front door painted and like all this
other kind of [__] so it's like that was
really expensive we're still I'm
starting to get to where I can start
worrying about the inside I would
actually one of these days I mean like
to get the driveway done yeah pavers
because we have like a super super super
long driveway and it's just white
concrete and it doesn't look that good
everybody else has all it's kind of
cracked and yeah [__] like that I would
like pavers but I know that's like
really expensive it'd be better if I
fill some of those cracks in with
something it was sand it all [__]
down with the [__] floor sander and
paint it
paint it in something kind of like I
don't know
something synthetic
maybe bed liner
well you have to like I'm not really
sure like what's allowed paint it paint
it in some kind of polyurethane and
throw colored sand on it the whole thing
look like [__]
red Sandstone or some [__] like that see
that would be pretty
yeah because somebody around here when
we were walking around the neighborhood
and I can't remember it's like way up
like a couple blocks up but they did
pavers in their like long circular
driveway and it looks amazing it looks
like really fantastic but I know that's
like super it's a pretty house
you just didn't eat a lot of work
yeah it needs like spicing up it's just
it basically just looks like a big
two-story rectangular box it doesn't
really have any
bells and whistles on it on the outside
yeah it's got to be double Landscaping
yeah but I mean you've done a really
good job like with the landscaping and
stuff and like the backyard looks good
like we you know you planted trees and
buy a chainsaw Hedges and [__] like that
around the outside where he planted like
hedges around the out Outer Perimeter
because our backyard
there's no fence there's no nothing it's
just like open so it's like open and
it's far but like then you can see like
the other house like over there so I'm
just kind of like you know so he's
planting like some Hedges that
eventually will be like tall enough to
like so you won't be able to see the
other house as much man this thing just
[__] swelled up like a fat as much
are you gonna are you gonna die no I'm
not gonna die but look at that man look
at you can grab it like it's a [__]
Apple it's hot too man
feel it grab it yeah I did earlier it's
birded I did that earlier and I was like
oh my God it's like oh man oh I was like
you sure you're all right you said eight
days it was like that on his ass
okay well I mean at least it's not on my
at least yeah
[Laughter]
Gekko is a club buddy of ours he's got a
real cute girlfriend well [__] I think
there might be married now aren't they
yeah I think they're right I think
they're married yeah Cole her name is
Cole yeah
and um she's a rattle over yeah y'all
would like her she's hot and [__]
jeky was a big dude all right kind of
quiet big guy he saw me down the club he
goes man you look amazing you look
amazing you know what I mean what
happened and I [__] told him that's
why I gotta do that so I got him hooked
up and he's [__] banging it up he's
[__] really trimming down getting big
he's working out a lot
but we're experimenting with different
stuff you know and sometimes sometimes
goes wrong we thought we could go Sub-Q
with 500 milligram [__] tests no you
thought wrong oh no it hurts incorrectly
yeah it's rough and muscle it's even
worse in fat yeah so don't do that don't
do it you learned something today
uh Mackie Max says how much is your
property tax I plan on buying a house
within five years maybe I get some I get
disabled veteran assistants and [__]
because I'm I'm [__] 85 percent uh
disabled according to the VA
I can still work
but uh I had medical retirement
says the head injury because of a head
injury so I can I get some of my [__]
taken off I gotta [__] go go back go
back and look exactly what it is
but it comes out of our
mortgage payment
yeah so we don't really feel it
he says all hooked up when you buy a
house should you save up the exact
amount or should you save till you have
more like 500 000 and just saved to 300
000 or 300 um
well I mean to be honest with you like
there's no way in hell that we could
have saved them no you had that amount
of money no we got this [__] [__]
basically zero down
yeah zero down yeah we didn't put that
one Florida is a [__] great place to
buy a house if you have
um and you have you know VA so you get
like a lot of breaks
um you know so you can get like low
interest loans and stuff like that yeah
they hooked me up
yeah
I mean we still got to pay for the [__]
gotta pay for it though which yeah not
cheap yeah it's
what did we end up paying for what did
we end up paying for 475 475 000 that's
awesome
so you know
our mortgage is 2500. yeah
but I mean expenses and [__] you got
well yeah we had to put a new roof on
that was what 20 grand
what's funny is 2500 that [__] that's a
decent apartment in New York
which is only a decent apartment here
you get a [__] mansion
well damn near I've noticed though that
uh the rent on the apartments around
here has been going way up too yeah you
really can't get a decent apartment in
Orlando anywhere yeah there's under 1500
2000. the state is getting flooded with
without a state people
so buying this house I mean used to be
remember the apartment that I had years
and years ago
um which wasn't great but it wasn't a
[__] you know what I mean it was
small but it was okay
that only cost me
6.75 yeah a month
if everything goes right and we hold on
to this house for four or five years I
can make money on it if I had to [__]
this out
um what would be better is to [__]
live here 15 years and if the [__]
[__] skyrockers it sell it because
this house at 475 if it floods because
they're building a bunch of [__] around
here okay brand new [__] housing
developments this might go up to [__]
700 I mean I'm kind of hoping because
the thing about in California this would
be a two million dollar house a million
and a half I mean it's a big I don't
remember what the exact square footage
is but
um
what is it 3 500 it's got two central
air systems one for the upstairs there's
one I don't remember it's a big house
big it's five bedrooms yeah three and a
half bath yeah and it's two stores in
kitchen it doesn't have and it's on
three quarters of an acre yeah no point
nine acres it's almost one acre where
yeah it won't they they shorted us just
a little bit so if it if it's one acre
you're able to do a bunch of [__] and
they didn't want it and they didn't want
to do that but the thing about this
neighborhood is that they all of the
lots are really big so like the houses
are fairly far apart yeah the
neighborhood we lived in before in
Sanford
um was the houses were really nice but
they were cut they were sort of close
together you know what I mean
but out here
we live in um it's called Black Bear
reserve and it's like a big sprawling
like neighborhood and they really tried
to like make the houses
you can just like like spaced far apart
so people have like really really big
you can just Google black bear Reserve
sandwiches Eustis Florida e-u-s-t-i-s
floor you'll see it it's one of the big
main neighborhoods yeah I mean and where
we live now you have a small house
section then you have the big house
sections it's all in the same area
because you know you got the small
houses here we're in one of the bigger
ones I can tell you exactly which one it
is but we're in one of the bigger houses
yeah and where we live it's pretty rural
yeah but the thing about it was that
when we moved to that house in Sanford
you know 11 12 years ago that was pretty
rural too and then by the time we moved
it was almost [__] almost in yeah it
was in the suburbs yeah suburbs they
were putting up traffic lights and [__]
when we left so if I can put new gas
stations yeah we couldn't believe like
how much it built it was a lot like in
the 10 years we lived there so I imagine
that's probably gonna happen here it is
happening I mean now when I drive to
work like I leave
at 6 30 in the morning and stuff it's a
while before you see any kind of
civilization it's mostly like Farms
um you know the odd house but there's
not really a lot out here it's mostly
Farms like I said
cattle Farms we're in farmland
some of the farmers Farms blueberry
farms yeah
but uh but the thing is is if you head
towards that biker bar they sold all
those Farms got sold and they put a huge
housing complex in there uh there's
going to be a lot of those kind of going
up and it's merging in with the stuff
from Mount Dora
yeah because Mount Dora is all happening
it's not a huge City but it's like a
it's um it's a classy English town yeah
it's small but a lot of people go it's
kind of known for antiques yeah and it
has like a lot of funky little shops
like I was thinking the other day do you
remember
I think it was on my birthday last year
and we went to that British pub that's
down there in Mount Dora and I was
thinking man we should go there again
what the hell is the name of that place
the magical meat Boutique or yeah like
that and it really is a British pub the
British people weren't living in there
working in there right yeah living in
there I think we went yeah we went for
my birthday last year because I was like
oh my God we have to go to this place I
think it's called the magical meat
Boutique yeah uh British chick walked
out there she's about 50 covered in
tattoos you know it's like a thick
[__] British accent and [__] [__]
taking her order she was hilarious fish
and chips and what'd you get you got one
of those something pie yeah I got a
Shepherd shepherd's pie I think and it's
like a British pub in there
and uh
had HP Sauce on the table and everything
is you know which I hadn't seen that
[__] in Forever
HP so HP Sauce was kind of like the
British version of A1 yeah it's sweeter
though it's kind of Tamarind flavor it's
good though I like HP I don't really
like Tamarind though
I'm not sure it is tamarind it just kind
of tastes like Tamarind to me it does
yeah well yeah that might be it does
kind of taste like it but I don't know
if that's what's like it's like A1 Sauce
just sweeter fruitier
but I liked it I first found it in Egypt
when uh at the mfo mission
we were doing that
we're at South camp and we were uh the
chow hall there was run by British
mercenaries ran it basically hired
contractors
they were the cooks and those
[__] were awesome and they ran
a uh their own little private bar
because they were they they would each
each dude got an issue of booze and they
were selling their own issue through
this through this British bar in the
middle of Egypt that only had American
guys in it
had a pitcher the queen and [__]
everything
they did and the fijians the Fijian
Colonel tried to go in there and they
were off limit from alcohol and they're
and he had his whole Entourage fighting
him because he was drunk trying to get
into the bar
and [__] they're holding him back and
he's [__] fighting to try to open up
the [__] bar front door and we're in
there like what the [__] is the Fijian
Colonel doing he's [__] blasted
and the British bartender who is also
like one of the head cook saw it and
[__] he reached up and grabbed a
[__] photograph of the queen and
jumped over the [__] bar and was get
out of here you savage down down you
savage down and the dude's gone
it was funny as [__] they drug him out
you British people like the power of Liz
the power of [__] the British queen
called him a Savage down you Savage and
the [__] guys cringing in front of
the [__] picture of the queen and
[__] that's crazy that's how they kept
the fijians were not allowed to drink
alcohol
on the mfo mission because it they're
Islanders and if you know anything about
Pacific Islanders we got them in the
[__] show here [__] love them
[__] serve with them micronesians
[__] uh [__] fijians [__] um
uh Hawaiians
there's just something genetically about
them they drink alcohol and they just go
berserk
they'll attack their best friends
sometimes they'll shove their heads
through walls
and so they're kind of like banned from
drinking alcohol but
they evolve with it I kind of feel
like though just like with many other
things that probably if you just like
Drank in moderation
regularly you could probably I've never
known I've never known an Islander to
drink in moderation as soon as they had
a few drinks in them that's it it's a
downward slope we I had
um some uh subscribers here I think that
um some Maori guys
on here and I think he confirmed that
that the Maori can't drink rule either
um
it's not the same experience for them
because we've been through thousands of
years of [__] selected right we come
from a long line of drunks
definitely like my actually my family my
family were did not drink uh weirdly I
didn't even start drinking until I was
older because it just I didn't grow up
around it but our ancestors all drank
going back to the Romans that's what I
mean so like all the ones that would be
bothered by that are dead if you're all
dead you don't have any descendants and
then hard liquor distillation came
for for Europeans in the 1700s I think
maybe late 1600s coming with gin and Jen
when it first hit England it was
considered to be like a crack epidemic
[__] bunch of people a lot of people
died uh they dragged themselves to death
yeah I remember hearing about it so but
we made it through that so we have we
have evolved through a process of
natural selection
now Africans evidently can handle
alcohol
so because they were drinking alcohol
back in Africa right they were making
fermented drinks
and um
Mexican Indians can drink it in any
Central and South American Indians
evidently North American Indians were
more susceptible to it
but not Central and South American
Indians it has to do with your
how much your ancestors drank
well like I said it kind of weeds out
the people that these livers couldn't
take it or yeah whatever you know what I
mean
which like I said I don't know that's
good or bad I'm just saying we're
resistant to it
Europeans had to drink it because there
was no Safe Water Supply especially
during the middle yeah isn't that [__]
up like they they basically was like
well it's yeah we have to drink alcohol
because the water will give you the
water will kill you dysentery yeah they
were living in cities and [__] right
no Safe Water Supplies it was much
better to just like drink alcohol they
drank beer and wine yeah
and then when distilled alcohol came
they'd put gin inside of water to purify
it and drink it yeah so which it works
yeah it works
but the thing is the thing is is that
Europe was in a constant Haze for
hundreds and hundreds of years they were
drunk
they said it wasn't until later on they
started making coffee because that
involves heating water yeah that they
started to come out of that
and now the Arabs brought them that yeah
there's actually
um I've read a couple because I'm
fascinated by food history and I'm
especially fascinated by coffee history
so I've read like at least three four or
five books about the history of coffee
um how it got introduced to Europe how
it like the cultural impact that it made
because it was like really huge and it
how how it ended up almost kind of like
fueling uh kind of like the
enlightenment a little bit yeah I feel
the enlightenment right we're drunk all
the time right they were instead of
being like man what were we doing the
last 300 years yes instead of being in
bars they were in coffee houses now
exactly and they were awake and they
were like not yeah yeah and they were so
yeah so the Arabs actually sobered up
the the Europeans yeah you can put it
that way yeah but yeah it's like it's a
fascinating it's fascinating history
there's like there's a lot of good books
about it I think the Arabs got those
beans from Africa
I think that's where they originally
came from then they ended up planting
them in Central America because they
could grow there
but if I remember correctly the the
Arabs got them from Trading with
Africans
yeah I think you might be right about
that like I said it's been a while since
I've read it but I have a couple I have
one
uh [__] I can't remember what it's
called but I have one like over there in
my bookshelves like about it it's like
really good
Africans can handle alcohol but I
guarantee I've seen this person I had an
Irish girlfriend you know Africa could
ever handle
the amount of alcohol that an Irish
woman can
I asked Fiona O'Shea could drink me
under the [__] table
I don't understand I would be like how
are you still drinking why are you and
she could drink far beyond what I could
drink and the Brits can drink right now
and she would still be standing and
still be basically coherent
bitch's name is Fiona
Fiona that is one of the most Irish
irishes she was from Court
yeah yeah
I was I mean when I lived in the UK
um
you know I wasn't a huge Drinker then
but I was like a you know a moderate
Drinker I could not believe the amount
of alcohol
just casually yeah they just drank all
the time and they were like like you
said they were just walking around they
were doing [__] and every time like
holy [__] she would drink me under
the [__] table and I swear to God
it's genetics It's gotta be
because there's no other explanation for
it
because I can drink a lot but you can
but I can't be as functional as she was
she'd be totally functional and I knew
that she had drank twice what I drank
I just I don't understand I kind of feel
like that and I don't know if how um you
know I don't know enough Irish people to
say but I do kind of feel like the Irish
are known for that for just being like
being able to like drink a lot and still
kind of like she was amazing maintained
she was amazing
I'm kind of amazed by that yeah she
could drink twice you've seen me on a
bender right she would do twice that
easily yeah and and be sober and I mean
I've seen you yeah real [__] up yeah
it takes a lot for you to get [__] up
to be fair yeah but once you I mean I've
seen you real real [__] up I've been
real [__] up
um irish-american but I have been
impurified by German and probably
[__] Native American Bloodlines have
come in and deluded that pure drunk
status that the irishers have given to
the world
I don't have the resistance of an
Irishman
wish I did
I don't know maybe I don't want to
because it costs more for you to get
drunk what's your once you're that
resistant to it Mr 88 said uh alcoholic
Irish is a stereotype based on a long
series of facts
based on the long series well like I
said I didn't get to Ireland when I was
over there but even when I was in I was
in Wales mostly and those [__]
could drink too it's like holy [__]
they're all related they would just like
drink all [__] day yeah and not think
a single thing about it yeah think a
single thing about it
and like nobody thought it was weird
like over here they'd be like oh my god
get to a meeting but like over there
they're just like whatever that was just
like what they did you know what I mean
yeah
oh yeah Fiona was definitely an
alcoholic but she could function I I
don't understand it trying to go to work
and hold a [__] job and be normal and
I couldn't doing what she I don't think
I could either like not drinking it was
just like you know we drink we don't
drink every night obviously we drink on
the show yeah sometimes in the evenings
we drink or not on the show but not
usually usually it's just like when
we're live streaming but um even then
I don't know I have two I have two I'm
usually fine the next day I can get up
at five I can sometimes I'll have a
little bit of a headache or I'll be a
little bit tired or something like that
but not bad like I can still function
and stuff but if I have more than that
yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna have some
problems like this
that's pretty good isn't it it is
actually it's better than I was
expecting Santa pineapple and [__]
Scott that's all we had in the house we
were out of juice it is Tom and Jenny
approved it's pretty good it is it's
pretty good yeah
Mr 88 said 35 square 3 500 square feet
is huge you could have his and her porn
rooms well here's the thing the upstairs
of this house we have
uh uh how many bedrooms are up here four
bedrooms there's four bedrooms
and two bathrooms up here
so I have so we have our bedroom Tom has
a man cave that has like all his movies
and his gun stuff and
his video games and all that
and then we have a gym
and then we have this room which is my
office so he has his own bathroom I have
my own bathroom which is nice because we
shared a bathroom like at the old house
obviously
but
um yeah it's more room it's honestly
more room than we kind of know what to
do with you know what I mean like I said
we can't really afford to put Furniture
in it so there's even so besides the
four bedrooms and the two bathrooms
there's also like essentially like a
second living room because obviously
there's a living room downstairs but
there's like kind of a there's like a
big open
room up here that I'm presuming people
would use as like a game room or a
living room upstairs and
we haven't really it's big so we don't
really have anything in it there's like
a couple of old chairs in there
um you know the mini fridge is in there
there's a toaster oven in there
it's a garbage can that's about it like
we don't have any like eventually I kind
of we kind of wanted to turn into like a
movie room like we'd have couches and
like a big TV and all this other kind of
stuff but we haven't done that yet
so I don't have the bunny we have a big
TV in the bedroom but is it but like I
said it's been we've lived here for a
long time we haven't painted anything I
painted this room
that's really the only thing that's been
painted the outside's been painted
because we had to because of the uh HOA
but we haven't paid anything else so
Tom's painting the bedroom and it's blue
uh he'll finish it tomorrow it's almost
done but all that's literally all that's
in there
is the bed
two uh nightstands with lamps on them
uh you know at least the the window has
curtains on it so there is that
um and then there's a TV
and the thing like that the TV sits on
that has the Xbox on it oh and there's
like a little uh kind of bookshelfy kind
of thing over there that we keep like
Pooky streets on and stuff that's it
there's nothing else in there there's
nothing on the walls
um
which is kind of it's so it's kind of
depressing
because it's like this room
I mean when we first got the house I
came in here early like I moved all my
[__] in first I said I'm setting up my
office so I could you know keep doing
videos and stuff like that so there
wouldn't be that much of a gap and I
said I want this room to be like exactly
like I want all my [__] in here this is
gonna be my room
so I painted it I put all my [__] up in
here and stuff like that so this is like
the coolest like my happy place
but like the bedroom
I kind of feel like it's just it was
just so bare for such a long time
there's no like I said there's nothing
on the walls or anything like that
there's nothing like interesting we're
gonna get us some Personality yeah we
really got to do something with that I
mean that I really didn't cost that much
to paint I mean what was it uh
80 bucks
80 bucks yeah two cans of paint I mean
it's a big room and it has high ceilings
might have been less
how much was that because didn't I get
you that yeah yeah it's 50 bucks 50
bucks uh
50 bucks for two cans of paint I think
it was 25.25 around at 25 to 30 a gallon
I had to pay a little extra on top of it
and put it on a card rebate it
it's such a pretty color
it's interestingly that's almost the
color because you went to Home Depot and
just picked it out because we were
talking about I was like I don't know
blue purple something like that like I
like dark colors like I said I don't
really like pale colors [__] that [__] I
don't like white colors yeah I like
color colors I like I like deep jewel
tones I like saturated colors like dark
colors I don't really like light colors
so look at the background yeah colors
yeah black blue
red purplish red oh yeah our [__]
bedroom was red it was [__] dark yeah
the old house like it was yeah it was
like blood red blood red I liked that
too you look good I like that too
because already was dark red because
I'll because our um our curtains and our
uh comforter are like black with kind of
like gold accents so we kind of had like
we almost had like a little bit of like
a dark Egyptian thing in the old bedroom
the walls were dark red
and then everything else was like black
and gold but like Egyptian looking
because we like like I had a mask of
Anubis which is up there and uh like a
lot of Egyptian looking uh stuff was in
there
but
this one like I said I kind of wanted
yeah blue or like a cool color yeah it's
because it's like almost a midnight blue
yeah it's similar to like my old house
that I used to have in Daytona a long
time ago that's about the same color as
my bedroom there was yeah maybe like a
touch darker but that's about like the
same it looks good on on camera too when
you have a dark because what it does is
it gives you an outline
if it's a white background or a light
color you'll lose the outline or the
silhouette of the person in a video or a
photo
and even just walking around a person
looks better on a black or dark
background
I feel like
um
I mean personally I always think like
colors pop better like on a dark
background too yeah like I think colors
look better like other bright colors
look better on like a dark background
and when I come into a house I want to
be in a space I don't want to feel like
I'm you know what I mean yeah
I like the interior design of say like
[__] newer restaurants and [__]
you know I mean corporate malls they all
have colors you know yeah there's colors
on the walls real colors not [__]
these weird beiges and [__] you know
see like I said it's like barely a color
barely a color right what was in here
was like this weird Peak not pink weird
Light blues it was like a barely it was
like baby blue but barely blue like if
you just kind of glanced at it you would
think it was just kind of like white or
like off-white yeah but you're like oh I
guess it's kind of blue
but see I don't like that kind of
bullshitty yeah I don't I don't like
that
I know that some people I know there's
kind of a thing where people are like oh
they like light colors because it makes
things look bigger or whatever so [__]
that I don't know I don't care about it
looking bigger I don't either I like it
to look cozy cozy and [__] I just
wanted to look cool I wanted to yeah and
I wanted to look like somewhere I want
to hang out and to be honest I
I like a cave like atmosphere yeah so do
I so do I I like a cave like I like to
feel like I'm enclosed yeah I do too
yeah I really so I like in a place and
something's happening so I like dark
colors I like dark colors and like super
saturated colors like super saturated
red or like super saturated blue like
against black I really like those I
don't like light colors at all
they're good for okay other people just
not for us
yeah look like a damn amusement park
yeah or a [__] a dark nightclub or a
[__] or something like that yeah see
it's like this kind of [__] like I love
this kind of [__] I love my black walls
I love like all my posters with all the
like yeah green and blue lights I wanted
to look like a [__] geologist
normally came in here they would think
this is some kind of satanic [__] I mean
it does look kind of satanic over there
but it's not it's just that's just how
we like it looks it looks Victorian the
victorians are kind of like that yeah
they like that kind of dark [__] and I
like that connection what was called in
saddened colors should we take any color
and mix it with black and kind of sadden
it yeah it's like and they did that kind
of stuff
and I still really like
that Victorian aesthetic you know what I
mean pretty much everything I'm just
really attracted to anything that looks
I don't know dark and old and decrepit
and everything like that I don't like
anything that looks like
white or Breezy or I don't know I'm just
not into it and like I know other people
like that and that's fine but it's just
like that's not my thing okay let me
read uh it's not my thing read read
comments up on the comments gotta Gretch
up on the comments catch up on the
comments uh mango says if you think the
Irish are bad then try keeping up with a
Slovakian yeah I've heard Eastern
Europeans are also yeah or Russian
Infamous guys and Eastern European
drawings sure
uh let's see Tammy says beige always
reminds me of nursing homes hospitals
and schools yeah it's anything that's
like white or beige or anything like
that I said that's the [__] that they
just paint the apartment because they
know you're gonna paint it afterward
this is just like the generic
color you're supposed to like change it
to your own personality you know what I
mean
uh Peggy Peggy says hi you guys I
haven't seen you guys for a little while
I love the glasses thank you very much
it has been a while because I've had the
how long have I had these glasses
oh it's months yeah you got them for me
a while I'm back a while back but uh
yeah I like well hi Pokey who said this
Peggy Peggy I don't see that it was that
was way up there
okay way up there Mr Eddie it said this
is my man cave Tom would appreciate it I
haven't yeah
Tom's got a nice man cave yeah yeah I
gotta paint that too you got to paint
that too because it still has this weird
bluish walls yeah but it's I mean you
have nice [__] on the walls though you
have like your Mad Max posters and yeah
Blade Runners yeah posters like all your
frames and stuff like that I wanna you
know what I was thinking about doing
some Rosetta's in there military
equipment [__] guns it looked like
something other damn Punisher yeah yeah
I was thinking in the bedroom like
um we should do like some kind of
I don't know because I've been farting
around so much with like that AI
art I was like I should print some of
that out and we should like frame it and
like put it up I think that'd be pretty
cool I wanna the art that you made for
the clubs remember that with the [__]
spooky women and [__] oh yeah yeah I
want those okay
yeah I got all those still yeah like all
the posters I did yeah
yeah I gotta I yeah
to print it out poster size right yeah
and yeah good quality yeah I can just
set it to
okay it's a print shop all right and
then uh we'll go to um go to the store
and we'll get we'll get uh
yeah they got uh frames at Dollar
General oh did it that right that size
um do they have poster frames
I've bought
um
like kind of I think up to 16 by 20 in
there
I have to look again
uh somebody says you put lava lamps in
your man cave
I got lighting effects but I don't have
any lava lamps I haven't thought about a
long lava lamps [__] I used to have
like a vintage lava lamp my grandma gave
it to me I remember correctly lava lamps
suck a lot of power because it's a light
that has to be hot enough to heat that
[__] gel to make it good and it's not
something you can leave running 24 7.
it'll cost you an arm and a leg there's
so many better lighting effects now that
project
that are a lot more efficient
so I go that way I like Bliss light
yeah we've got like I said we've got one
of those in the in the bedroom I got two
of them yeah it's just it's IT projects
like it looks like um like nebulas
nebulas with a swirling Galaxy it's like
it's like um green and blue and red like
RGB I got the Bliss one and the Bliss
light too the Bliss like one isn't quite
as nice as Bliss like too you want to
get Bliss light too that's what you want
it's worth the money
if you can get that for like about 35
40.
Senora stick says Tom and Jenny no
satanic Panic at your house no I swear
if some if if anybody ever came in here
and like commented on it I would know
that I couldn't be friends with that
person
[Laughter]
be bothered
by my [__] who would be bothered by my
[__]
it's not satanic Jenny just likes horror
movies that's all
um yeah yeah mango says slovakians are
top of the tree I tried and I lost yeah
man
Americans are lightweight compared to
Europeans when it comes to drinking we
are I will yeah I will say that and I
like to make jokes about like what
drunks we are and stuff like that but
it's like I'm sure like many Europeans
could just drink us out of the table
they would think we were tea toddlers
they probably were I heard that
Australians are good at drinking too I
have heard that also I've heard that
also I don't really know that many
Australians but yeah
uh Tammy said what about the light they
used to run during the shows
which one the one that said um
we used to have the on well we still
have it the on-air sign oh it's up there
yeah yeah well the thing about it still
works and everything like that but
I didn't have anywhere because it's USB
and I didn't have anywhere to plug it in
that you that the um camera could see
that the camera could see because the
cord isn't long enough
so I tried it out like there was nowhere
to plug it in on the side of the
computer like and put it behind it's
like that so I couldn't do it so I just
like put it up there
but did you start by the time we used to
have that laser display oh yeah maybe we
experimented with that a couple times
but we did that well we had a green
screen because remember we bought the
green screen
yeah and we put that behind us and I
said oh we're gonna put some but then it
took so with my old program it took so
long to like uh process yeah the video
because of all the activity that was
going on the background like all the
lasers and [__] yeah that we just didn't
do it again because it just sucked up
now what happened when we get the new uh
webcam if we have that [__] running on
1080p
something like a bliss light would
actually work good behind us but the
thing is is all that's a distraction in
a certain way the show doesn't really
need that
it just doesn't I mean it just sucks up
more data
anything moving you see this case we
ever get too boring it's like
everybody's like ooh just look at the
pretty because the wave extremes this
area back here it's showing a constant
image of the data
which
things where when you have a when you're
when you're streaming video and a lot of
it a lot of the image isn't moving it
just repeats the old data
when you start putting a bunch of moving
[__] there the data stream it has to
like it has to compensate for it yeah
because like oh my God new shit's
happening yeah all the time so you just
kind of overwhelming the Stream
and like I said I kind of feel like a
lot of times this was back then I don't
know yeah well that yeah that was the
old program I was using I mean it
probably it would probably take a long
time now but not as long as they used to
yeah but like you said it's kind of like
I've seen I don't know I've seen other
channels doing that and I'm just like I
don't really I don't know I don't know
if we need that necessarily
like all that kind of stuff in the
background like you said maybe it's too
distracting yeah how old I've been
streaming uh an hour and 49 minutes okay
all right
mango said and I've been drinking since
12 p.m and it's 2 15 a.m here now well
man God bless you because
we just I just started drinking yeah
7 30 when we started the show
because I've been at work all day so I
couldn't drink I mean I could but I'd
probably get in trouble
I wouldn't really be able to get [__]
done you know what I'm saying if there's
anything you guys want to talk about go
ahead and drop it to Super Chat and
[__] we'll uh we'll move the
conversation down that way if not we're
just gonna sit here and drink these two
drinks and then get the [__] out
Sean says Blade Runner is an exceptional
movie it is yeah and also Blade Runner
what did you think of Blade Runner 2049
because I also loved I liked Runner 20
yeah
Mega said God bless my liver yeah
mine too I just I don't even want to
know what mine looks like to be honest
with you I don't even want to know
but
I was wondering if because we have all
this stuff in the background all the
time
I was wondering if people didn't know
what some of it was I mean obviously
that's nosferati you can see that and
you can see the Frankenstein one and you
can see the suspiri one that's like a
witch right there that's actually this
this is from the superior remake I just
really like I mean I I like the original
Superior better but I just really like
that poster from a graphic design
standpoint
um yeah and that one up there is uh Bell
winch yeah witch yeah this one right and
then the one over there that's
um the red one
I'm pointing the wrong direction uh
that's actually a Bauhaus poster that's
the single poster from The Passion of
lovers and it was signed by David J I
bought it I bought it off of him yeah
um and I also have the picture like
right behind Spock's shoulder is also
David J and he signed that as well like
from Bauhaus and Love and Rockets
and the one above that is Bay of blood
because I got a whole set I don't even
know if they still have these I found
this [__] on Amazon
there was a whole set of giallo
um like their posters but they're you
know they're like eight by tens
from all different movies and I got them
for I think it was like 12 bucks man and
I I was 10 I think it was 10. so I got
Bay of blood there is what else is back
there
um lizard and a woman's skin eyeball
bird with a crystal plumage there's all
kind of like cool ones I don't even have
them all framed because I didn't have
enough frames for all of them but yeah I
got those oh and also back there there's
like an Edward gory that I got when they
did an Edward gory
um
thing at the Orlando Art Museum and I
went to see it like several years ago
and I got that poster there Sean said
both Blade Runners were good exceptional
yeah
I like the new Dune and eventually the
second Dune is coming out soon I want to
see that one also
I like the first one it's pretty good
read the book I like that I like the
original movie too the old movie The
Dino De Laurentiis movie
even though it was [__] an
Abomination I still thought it was a
[__] great movie
Senora stick says Jenny you don't have
one of those uh deceptive flasks like a
statue that's allowing day drinking I've
thought about it for sure I used to have
a flask I don't know what happened to it
but it looked like a flask so you
couldn't really like hide it
hahaha
have I seen the void yes uh that's a
great [__] movie I don't think I've
ever
kind of feel like I probably should for
my channel I think I wrote about it a
long time ago
but I don't know
I'm pretty sure I did but I don't think
I've rewatched it like to do for the
show but I probably should because
that's like an excellent excellent movie
and let's see what else is going on
Dune has a strange popularity
meaning the David Lynch one
yeah I don't know
there it goes mango yeah thank you mango
are you looking forward to Robert Eggers
remake of Nosferatu for me he has yet to
make a bad film I think it will be good
Robert Eggers is
I mean he is like really into
like old films and like making [__] look
like old films like he's really into
like the art of filmmaking so I think if
anybody's gonna remake Nosferatu I think
he's like the best dude to do it
so yeah I'm very excited about it
like I said we need
we need to see Renfield too I'm excited
about that didn't okay didn't a couple
of you guys I don't remember who it was
Styx said that Dune is a very dry
material top yeah it's dry it's like
reading the Bible
but that's part of that's part of the
I don't know that's part of the [__]
Allure to Dune as a book
it's like it's like reading something
out of the Old Testament it's you're
like reading something that actually
happened but in a way it happened a long
time ago it's just weird I did I I only
read the first dune book I didn't read
the other ones but I liked it when I was
just first reading it it was weird
and um
uh Frank Hubert's a real
Herbert Herbert yeah it's Herbert
Herbert yeah Frank Herbert's real um
intelligent I think he's uh I think he
was an ecologist
and the world that he created was
fascinating just this [__] in a
distant future across all these
different planets what had happened to
Mankind and how they all damn evolved
into different species of people
you know
um it was just
and he would just say [__] matter of
factly you know
about the things that they were doing
and they were doing bizarre [__]
just
a lot of other people got sucked into it
there's a good world there's every bit
is good if not better than Star Trek
it's just that the way the books are
written they didn't
they wouldn't make a good series you
know they've tried to make all these
little Dune miniseries that it doesn't
it doesn't [__] translate to film or
series real well but that last Dune
movie was close man that was pretty good
that was a pretty good adaptation
yeah I don't think the look was right
but I still I accepted it I mean
I I think that was probably as good as a
adaptation as you're ever gonna get for
me
the dino DiLaurentis version they got
the look right that that for me that's
the way Dune is supposed to look
the new one it's acceptable but I prefer
the old the look of the old the look of
the old yeah I get that yeah
I get that
they were trying to make it I don't know
well
the David Lynch one which you know he
famously kind of wanted his name taken
off of but that was more
over the top I guess and I guess like
the new one was trying to be a little
bit more grounded which probably was
maybe closer to the book but maybe not
as visually
arresting as the 80s one oh man the
costumes and the way the the I really
did like the look of the 80s yeah it
kind of had a Mystique to it
I mean I I love David Lynch he's my
favorite
[Music]
um
and I know that he didn't really want to
do that moves you know because he
usually does his own projects so it's
just that was somebody else's project
that kind of got voiced on him
so I get it I don't love that movie but
it's interesting at least you know
it's interesting
uh let's see I thought they were saw
something else Miss ready said the Witch
Is Awesome it is I love that movie I
don't think Tom's ever seen it heavy
which one the witch the robber daggers
yeah
you I don't would you like it
I don't know hard to say
it's um you know it's set in
Old Times old times 16 17th century and
it's all in that
language like it's all in that kind of
Old English right thing like that kind
of archaic modern name right yeah but
it's creepy as [__] okay it's really
creepy but uh it could go either way
like you might love it or you might hate
it it's one of those movies that I'm not
really sure if you would like it or not
it might be one of those movies that I
think he's gonna hate it but then like
he watches it and he's just like oh my
God that was awesome I'm not really sure
I loved it but I don't know if I don't
know if he would like it or not
chongora said Lynch was asked by Lucas
to direct Return of the Jedi but
declined yeah I remember reading about
that
which now I kind of want to like pop
over to the universe where it's David
let's try to return to the Jedi
we see how that turned out
Mr idiot said I'm proud my children are
some are so film literate when they saw
Anya Taylor Joy promo material for the
Super Mario movie They said That's the
girl from The Witch I smile too you're
raising him right raising them right
she's great I really like her but yeah
uh let's see
oh what I was gonna say before
um I just remembered didn't a couple of
you guys recommend
a movie called soft and quiet
because I'm pretty sure I wrote it down
a little because I saw it like on one of
my little scraps of paper that I write
[__] down on and
it's on Netflix right
because I was gonna watch it the other
day but I didn't get around to it
but I remember I just was scrolling
through Netflix and I just remembered a
couple of you guys had recommended that
and that maybe I should watch it but
like I said probably okay so we gotta do
Breakfast Club
Sunday because Louie sent it to us a
long time ago and we never reviewed it
and we just watched it again last night
like with all the extras and stuff so
we're going to talk about that but I
also just noticed that Amazon Prime
added terrifier too and I was like
I kind of got to see that I'm just like
because everyone was talking about how
[__] gory it was and I'm just like
yeah a challenge accepted also Tom wants
to see it because we really liked the
first one so the first one was like a
lot of fun
[Music]
um
senior six had ever thought about
writing Netflix like writing a Netflix
series or something like that I mean
it's occurred to me I if Netflix came to
me and said hey we want to like make one
of your things into like a series okay
like that would happen well you know
Netflix's not coming to us they got
their own people that they [__]
choose from
all right how long I've been streaming
two hours okay let's go ahead and uh
Victor said terrifier too was so good
okay yeah we gotta watch that one yeah
well we were gonna watch it last night
but I was like oh my God it's so long
um I said so let's just do breakfast
club because I know that's shorter and
it's like it's fantastic but I know it's
a lot of people say well like I said I
want to see I'm just curious because
everyone was talking about oh my God
it's one of the goriest movies ever I'm
like yeah we'll see we'll see
challenge accepted
[Laughter]
yeah mango said it's fantastic it's a
long movie but it flies by
so all right
like I said I'm pretty sure they just
added as Amazon Prime so
I was gonna watch it but I decided I'd
wait for you because I know you want to
see it
because remember we saw the first one
Shauna air came over yeah
all right you ready to go yes get
something to eat though
yeah I'm pretty hungry actually yeah you
haven't eaten all day I haven't eaten
all day you've been painting yeah you're
doing all this [__] like I said I just
had like a little slice of Focaccia when
I got home and that's all I've had like
pretty much all day all right so we're
gonna wrap it up because it's 9 30.
so hopefully you guys have a good Cinco
de Mayo have a good day tomorrow we'll
be back on Sunday talking about
breakfast club so you know 80s John
Hughes movies you're gonna if you're
into that uh you know drop by and
hang out with us but uh yeah thanks
everybody for dropping by thanks for
your super chats and we'll see you guys
on Sunday
good night